hello my name is santo Antonov and I'm a
senior data scientist at the company
called clear says I'm going to present a
talk on monadic programming and its
development utilization involve from
language
so this talk the the original subtitle
was was Maneri programming the title was
phonetic programming and the subtitle
was with applications to data analysis
machine learning and so forth
this was also like few months ago when I
made it I am actually much more
interested to talk about the background
and how to use monadic programming but a
lot here to a point for the original
original plan of this so I'm going to
zoom here a little bit
this display points which I mentioned
there when I program can be used in
several ways what I'm professing here
and what I'm proposing is to use it as a
software design pattern you can use it
also the fundamental construct so I can
like say in Haskell it's it's a
fundamental concept like class in
object-oriented programming languages
and around monitor you basically build
the language I'm not saying we should be
doing this in mathematical war from
language yeah I think is what you can do
it with you can do different
implementations using Minari programming
and I can also define probably defined
everything I have shown here through
some kind of type system either made
custom made through pattern matching
called the new type system being
developed but this is I'm not doing this
here it's a set of dealing with types
I'm just generating code for the mods so
I'm using the capabilities of
Mathematica to do meta programming and
generate code so the outline of the talk
it's yeah we'll see an introduction or
example I'm not sure to what degree we
should go for the theoretical background
in although monitors the definition
comes from category theory you really
don't need to know the algebraic origins
the the thing is waveform with with more
notches but
it is very easy to to kind of get lost
you know with it to start the fury
behind it but it's actually much simpler
and I hope I can convey the simplicity
you know in during the talk so one of
the big things I want to discuss is the
white why you use mod codes and you know
what are the consequences and I'm going
to discuss how what is the general
workflow I'm proposing here with the
code generation and we'll see the
applications so for those of you who
don't come and met me before I worked
for Wolfram research seven years I was a
kernel developer working muslim
numerical numerical software and miracle
algorithms marry programming you know
why I'm looking into this
I mean well multiple reasons some of
these little bits like people say when
when vote from language I'm of America
is going to mature to use models well
you can use models from the get-go it's
just you know people don't know the
functional programming came into focus
in the latest years through both mostly
machine learning and parallel
computations and yeah some of the
languages like say scholar they do use a
very strongly Malad based the jobs
they're in automatically you can use
models but it's also not necessarily
needed so this can I'm just loading some
examples here but all right so let's and
you can see here this by the way it just
loads the data and here this big code
you can completely ignore is just making
the different names for different data
sets you know more manageable data more
presentable data so this is what is the
monadic pipeline and so this particular
thing here it's how you start the
monitor with certain data so now this is
a classification machine classification
example and I have split the data here
into training contesting here this 75%
for training 225 for testing you can see
what I have computed the summer is here
and then I extend further the the Minari
pipeline with some some cross tabulation
of what is my my my labels of diet and
survived so I actually want to see what
is the representation in the rest of the
data for these two labels so if I
continue with the Minari pipeline well I
removed the last line but I basically
replaced it with this classifier on the
forest actually this should be alright
so yeah you can see well the classified
it run again we didn't show the results
so this actually here it's going to show
show the is going to run the classifier
show the results show curacy and so
forth so what is this you know like I
mean so this is basically the monadic
pipeline if I can summarize you can see
summary here of the operations this is
actually a different Murray pipeline but
it kind of goes in the same way alright
so so the first operation is to lift
lift the data into the model and then
the rest of the rest of the the
functions were navigating through this
manat space so this is how we can think
about monadic programming we have two
operations one is one is the unit
operation and this here and the other
one is the binding operation this is
basically what I said right now the unit
operation lifts the data into the
monarch space whatever modern space we
have envisioned and then with the bind
operation you navigate through it this
is a typical pattern in mathematics like
say for the analysis you transform you
transform your you know your signal into
some phase space and then you do stuff
in the phase space and then map back
so this is a this is the one way to look
at it and let me return to before going
to the theory of a reticle background it
seems that this is kind of helpful to
mention if you have undone Minari
problem before or you think you haven't
you probably have and so this pipeline
operator perspective or chaining
corporations in a pipeline manner its
fairly well-known and SQL for example
provides a good example of pipeline
chaining and the other thing is of
course you know UNIX operation
operations on the command line with
pipelining so here that the definition I
have been have been using it's fairly
simple it is actually the original
definition which is used in Haskell
there's another definition which it's
it's equivalent they actually probably
several other definitions but the one
here it's the one I'm adhering to and if
you look at the this formula here it's
actually fairly fairly I think it says
it all
so we start with our we start with our
initial object when I said and this M is
what it's produced by the unit command
you need to operator
it puts whatever data you have into the
model and then after that the binding
cooperation is just looking for certain
for certain combination of signatures
and then call successively the functions
they're very trivially just can be
implemented in this way so it's like if
you look into I mean you can see with
this fall to parade actually I don't
know does everyone see it let me so you
can see with this fault operator but
yeah you just kind you just you know
make the the chain the chain calling for
the functions so what I was showing you
earlier with this arrows
you know like which which are here right
like the arrows between it it's this is
just the overloading you know of the sum
of the internal internal operators in
North America in order to make things
more convenient and so it is important
to to look into the monarch laws and
this is the this is what makes a model
basically these two operations plus this
this monarch laws define what monarch is
the big thing about it is but it's just
an dysfunctions is they just associative
where it's an associative operation
and the unit function so the binding
function is a very associative e2 law
which holds and the and the unit
function is just left and right identity
to what Association so I mean if you
look into this here I'm saying what you
can put you can group in arbitrary
manner the order of the functions
matters but how do you group them do you
do first f1 f2 and then every and
whatever or do you make some kind of
parenthesis grouping in between I mean
it shouldn't matter this it this
observation here is what involved from
language list and apply they do form
Amanat so just because of this you have
already done monadic program basically
imagine what when you when you program
in involve from language any function
you write raps the result you know in a
list and then your any type you want any
time you want to apply a function you
are actually using the the operator
apply and so this is closely related to
something called cartesian close
categories and cartesian post category
well I didn't want to respect speak too
much about here but I will apparently so
when you have a bunch of arguments you
know like obviously if you group them
you know in some way this a Cartesian
product but can you add to your
Cartesian products can you add functions
so instead of having just list of three
elements I want to have list of three
elements wherever they are and my other
element to be the first one say to be a
function and so what is the if I try to
do that what kind of mathematical
structure I'll have and this is the
Cartesian clothes category this is
extremely important in other fields in
in other fields in mathematics like say
functional analysis it is it it category
here it deals with this kind of
universalities and analogies between
different mathematical disciplines so
I'm going to continually form with my
exposition here so what is I mean what
is the big deal and you know why do I
mean I'm not sure how much you are
convinced from the short example earlier
to about Minari programming but the
computational pipeline I mean it is
actually providing some kind of you know
it does provide some sort of very very
easy to understand sequence of steps so
it is very convenient this here what you
see these comments which I did I did in
a specific way now Milotic programming
this arrow can be programmed in some way
so one of ways to look at Minari problem
in keys but it gives you a programmable
semicolon this means but the semicolon
or whatever operator separates your
commands can be programmable buts a very
interesting property I will show I will
show at the end of the talk how I have
produced this picture is basically and
made another monitor which and I
programmed the Dinaric arrow in such a
way that I can produce this code with
comments and so this is the big the big
thing one of the big things about it and
so this is the first two points here so
the other thing is what you can and I'll
try to convince you about this you can
provide different polymorphic behavior
to the functions to the functions here
and so although you have used this
wrapper M what is exactly here you can
have different behavior on different
data like where several systems which
which do that and it is very powerful
powerful way of doing of doing
computations what what model programming
gives you is the ability to very
flexible very flexibly very quickly
construct some sequence of C points
sequential computations sequences of
computations a computation but can be
done in whatever kind of envision
different combinations of elements this
is this is what is the most important
thing and so one of them if you read
about about Moritz one of the big thing
you are going to to kind of see at first
is how to program that may be moral
and so I mean you can see here in this
particular case I've been low I loaded
this package
maybe monitor generated the maybe code
and here this this here you know a let
me see you just alright so I'll run it
several times so alright now here you
can see what this everything is fine and
good meaning I did produce some random
real data six numbers I echoed this data
so you see it here the first part then I
generally called a function on on my
pipeline the pipeline has this value has
this list of six numbers as a as a value
then I call the function total and now
here I'm actually checking is is this
total sum less than three if it is less
than three I'm going to produce a
failure like what you see here and if it
is not I'm just going to multiply it by
two which which it's happening here if I
run this several times I'll I'll run
into fella right
and so this one of the things about
about monads manat programming we're
actually handling failure more or less
gracefully and you can see how this
basically says look I mean obviously the
sums less than three and because of this
we have here this failure so this by the
way the way I have put the formula here
and it should be obvious it's like
trivial to trivial to implement when you
implement this kind of mods you just
need to have different behavior for the
failure symbol when you develop simple
happens in the pipeline and when you
have and you know when you have the
regular values the expected values thank
you
and so this sum this is going to I'm
going to illustrate it probably further
with polymorphic behavior since I have
only say ten 15 minutes for the rest of
the talk and we actually what I want to
show how is this done in ah so you know
there are two styles of data wrangling
one is very similar to data set
basically you have objects similar to
data set where called data tables and
you kind of inwardly kind of manipulate
the data tables Java approaches to use
this monadic pipeline and so you can see
here it's actually fairly easy to
understand you get some data set with
Star Wars you add a new name which is
calculates the body mass index for the
whatever is the Star Wars character then
we select those of we select only the
the name and the and the actually a
sequence of of columns between name and
mass and then we we order them in the
descending order and so further we can
use the same I mean same thing we can
make this magnetic pipeline which
actually you know groups groups it by
species thus whatever kind of sums of
the total mass of the species then takes
the species which gave more than one or
whatever so you can see the pulmonic
pipeline symbol is this one and as I
said you know it's like I mean you can
easily first of all you can see what how
similar these two SQL is also you can
see what obviously can do this like in
same thing something like data set now
further about this is what well do you
see this so this actually enough this
particular thing is implemented really
well because it doesn't matter what is
your data structure you can actually do
the monadic pipeline over the data
frames which is the native the native
data structure now you can do it with
SQL databases we can do it with spark
structures and so we this is the
polymorphic behavior I'm talking about
so it's very convenient you write it in
one way you know if one of these data
structures and you can produce it with
yours imagine in Mathematica with
database lane you have SQL execute
instead of SQL execute cone and then a
string prove the SQL operation you
imagine what cone can be not just a
connection to a database but also data
set so it's like a similar type of
behavior all right I'm going to I need
to speed up a little bit here this my
favorite flight unfortunately and I
maybe I shouldn't skip it let me think a
little bit well category theory actually
has been he's been called the fear of
Astrakhan
if you hear started general algebra it's
you know especially from the western
countries at the time I was touring
general algebra but you got a theory was
you know it was it was getting
prominence
it was embraced by the French
mathematicians and so like for example
the old use category theory for you know
unit testing can software and other
things like that so it's in general they
you know lots of Europeans use like say
huh scale f-sharp whatever and so they
use Minari programming so I personally
think what category fury was made to be
some sort of a shell theory it's to see
it is a theory which lets you use
mathematical formalism for analogies
between different mathematical or
scientific theories and because of this
you can actually make some developed if
just if this mathematically phrased
analogy you can manipulate it
symbolically produce something else
actually see if some fear is
underdeveloped in some way develop it
further and so forth that's fascinating
but when it comes to programming in to
some extent this is a shell type of
perspective I wouldn't I wouldn't use it
to make a fundamental structure and then
use it you know to make a programming
language but well people do and now if
you want if you're interested in the
rest of the topics here I'll you know I
can discuss it after the after the talk
so this is the proposed workflow we
basically you have you start start with
one idea about about monads and model
programming you try to find do you have
any mod which exists already let's say
in my github repository and if we if
there is no more like that you you
implement your own mod but if they is
you start to use this basic model and
then you implement additional pipeline
functions you start making pipelines if
you're not satisfied with your pipelines
you program better functions and thank
you and then you go go further let me
actually show you this in practice so I
am a big fan of the so called great
conversation this is
and just so the great I'll show you what
I mean so I programmed this so I have a
bunch of speeches of American presidents
and so for example here you can see so I
have done what I have done here and let
me put it in the middle it's any kind of
collection of documents books articles
wherever you extract is all somebody has
told you what are the topics of these
documents and then you want to make a
timeline or you want to see what is the
conversation between the authors in
these documents if you do it for all
Western books you know for the last say
four thousand years you can see what is
the conversation between the authors in
the last you know four thousand years so
it's a fascinating concept I like it a
lot some people have worked very hard on
it and I'm sorry if I if I assume it's
not going to be obvious I'm going to
show you what the topics are so this
particular notebook outlines this
procedure it does actually find the
topics but you can see how this
representation here how it can get messy
especially code wise I mean I know what
is going on and instructing I'm
extracting the remains I'm doing you
know so here's some topics you want to
get closer to see what topics are and
you can see some of these topics oh well
you know as I said this is like topic
extraction with matrix factorization and
so they say presumably vayne makes sense
you know I can do also say statistical
Tesoro centex cetera but this actually
it's a very I mean you can see this code
it's I mean just to write about it it's
you can get lost in the details like say
this exposition here gets lost in the
details and so what I did is what I
actually did refactor it quite a lot so
I have this this model here which
actually was not interesting but you can
see this non-negative matrix
factorization is tucked in and what the
result is is what I do actually have now
after I have read the data and you know
do some statistics
you can see my Minari pipeline here it's
very it's very clear and concise we put
the text into the Mon art we make the
document term matrix in removing stop
words we apply somewhere weighting of
the terms with the topic extraction and
after with the topic extraction you can
see I produce some statistical to Saurus
and you know like map the conversation
some heat map and so forth so this this
is actually one of the things I was
saying but it's extremely useful to use
monarchs form for code for code
refactoring as a design pattern
this was the illustration what I was
showing right now so for because of time
and then you kept to three minutes here
it's not although we are discussing
pipelines this is not I mean let me just
generate the monitor here
so I generate the mods with a prefix
state statements a steam on and so here
I'm basically calling this this pipe
once and you can see I can have optional
optional acceptance of results and then
you know basically the before the what a
run before the result was not accepted
because one of the elements was less
than three so I think is what we can do
we can you can apply functions and so
forth this actually so don't get fooled
by the this arrow here you can have very
nonlinear computations inside this this
this pipeline so another thing I want to
mention is in this kind of the the
closing thing which I really wanted to
discuss a lot but I guess you know I
wouldn't have time it's this is an older
style I programmed for monadic
programming it's numeric parsing you can
see how I have programmed the the
parsers of different symbols so if I
evaluate this in producing this so you
can see this says you know I'm just
parse it and you can say I can of so
what I mean but all right let me
convince you what this is actually doing
something interesting like let's say
here a field
and doesn't like something yeah all
right and then now you can see this
operation said okay wrapped around
science now if I do this systematically
for everything here you see I can
actually extract name and extract all
the elements in this parsing in this
parsing curve in this from this parser
when it parses different different
sentences if I remove some some part
here and I say this should be also
possible and etc one of the one of the
the big things is and I tiny really need
to mention this why use Maneri
programming why say not use
object-oriented programming
object-oriented programming you made
rigid rigid backbone structures and you
flesh them out with concrete concrete
objects so this is what software
architecture is you really want control
it's also like inversion of control like
you don't let the the developers do
their own strategic decisions basically
the Hollywood principle don't call us
we'll call you
or the Greyhound you know leave the
driving to us and so forth now the
backbones this this is very good and
it's each case its own purposes
especially for production level software
it is very important feature but imagine
especially for experimentation and
especially now if you your developer so
you're the user of your library or
software is actually more sophisticated
then actually having at your fingertips
the ability to construct different types
of computations like backbone type of
computations is really important and
then the polymorphism with the
polymorphic implementations you can have
a very very flexible system of doing
different things and so and if you
design your system in this way it is
going to be much more first of all it's
going to be much more granular because
you need to actually make the individual
components much more independent
because they can be a bit early put in
some pipeline and yeah I think is but if
you do it also like that some other
things like say doing conversational
agents or you know domain-specific
languages which we mot would be much
easier to to program like what I showed
you earlier in the previous slide with
the with the with in the previous
section with the melodic parsing you can
this actually here it's an expression in
Mathematica if I put field this kind of
heads of functions everywhere I can
actually interpret them appropriately in
a certain context and get you know all
the monadic kind of you know pipelines
I'm doing they can be you know
interpreted in a way I would want so I
said I'm going to talk about this model
but the programming semicolon you can
look at I get very well documented the
whole thing so you can see in the
references here you can find you can
find different different references this
is actually very well-documented as I
said if I go to probably I can find some
of this maybe with me so let me see if i
press this link this this was supposed
to be a high pollen yeah well anyway
visa this based on article and BA from
get happened in community about numeric
programming and discusses in great
detail the theoretical theoretical proof
you know quistis and how to do it so as
I said I don't know do you use do use
any design patterns but imagine with
Association you started using causation
in math America and vote from language
this new structure and this gives you
the ability to produce to use
object-oriented programming in a sense
but then you are wondering what else you
know how do I use the actual methods
well actually you can hook up the demo
night programming pipelines with your
context your you know association this
the Maneri pipeline I showed you earlier
in the beginning of the talk
with with the classification it's done
in this way I'm basically taking in
different data in some context and then
I use whatever functions to manipulate
them and do something for the things
with that alright so I yeah I mean you
can look at this links you know my
github repository I plan to do some
other stuff as I said this is very well
I have very well documented the approach
I'm proposing here and you can see it
obvious
this presentation is saturated with
links thank you for your attention the
next talk is mine so if you have
questions about this talk I'll be you
know you got to hear and answer all
right thank you
yeah I wanted to do it before the
presentation here but a human probably
tonight or tomorrow I'll put it on yeah
yeah yeah I did it yeah we taught the
digital humanities class and yeah in
Oxford so it was related to that and yes
I to some extent this is the reason I
showed it I actually I wasn't satisfied
how it looked and I had to refactor the
code in order to look better yes
right so when you like associations
obviously you know you can associate any
kind of data that key key data with a
key so it's basically this part of the
objects you already have now the
question is how do you hook up
particular type of methods to the
associations if you do this with Amanat
with this monarch code like my I have
code generators for the monitor so you
specify what kind of what is the one of
the prefixes of the of the monarch
pipeline functions it will generate the
functions and say I have select I start
with a mod called context monitory
voyages this context model has
Association and you can manipulate
manipulate values from the pipeline to
them in the context extract them in the
context do other stuff so basically you
can do sort of object-oriented but this
Maneri programming now implementation in
this way obviously you can do it in
other ways actually in one of the links
I have in Mathematica stack exchange
there was a question about this when to
use global variables and when not to use
and how to do it all right I need to
prepare for my next talk and yeah thank
you for you know for the questions